ونذهب معكم الى زاويتنا الاخباريه مع شبكه
مراسلي مساء العربيه وكل يوم مراسم ينضم
الينا من المدينه المنوره مراسم مساء
العربيه سلطان السلمي اهلا بك السلطانه
نتحدث اليوم عن توافد ملايين الزوار
والمصلين خلال الثلث الاول من شهر رمضان
مبارك حدثنا اول عن نجاح الخطه التشغيليه
خاصه مع زياده العدد بنسبه 47% بحسب
الاحصائيات
اهلا بك واهلا بكافه مشاهدي مساء العربيه
نتواجد حاليا داخل ساحات المسجد النبوي
نتحدث على نحو 13 مليون مصلي قاموا باداء
الصلوات هنا في المسجد انه النبوي قبل
قليل انتهت صلاه المغرب وافطر الصائمين
هنا في ساحات المسجد وداخل المسجد النبوي
كما يظهر امامكم حجم الاعداد الكبيره التي
تخرج من المسجد النبوي الان بعد الانتهاء
من اداء صلاه المغرب ويحرص البعض منهم على
القيام بالافطار هنا في ساحات المسجد لما
هنالك من روحانيات كبيره نتحدث على ارقام
وخطه تشغيليه ضخمه شاهدها المسجد النبوي
هذا العام وتحديدا لاستقبال اكبر عدد ممكن
والعمل بكامل الطاقه التشغيليه نتحدث على
12 13 قرابه 13 مليون مصلي قاموا باداء
الصلوات هنا في المسجد النبوي نتحدث على
ارقام كبيره من ضمنها اكثر من 750 الف شخص
قاموا بزياره الروضه
نتحدث على توزيع سته وثلاثين الف تصريح
يومي لدخول الروضه تم تقسيمها بين النساء
والرجال 50% للنساء وخمسين بالمئه للرجال
نتحدث على 400 طن من المياه زمزم ينقل
يوميا من بئر او من مصنع زمزم في مكه الى
المدينه المنوره وتحديدا في المسجد النبوي
لتوزيع عبوات زمزم نتحدث على توزيع 82 الف
وجبه افطار يوميا في ساحات وداخل المسجد
النبوي لتقديمها للصائمين بشكل تطوعي
ومجانا نتحدث على اكثر من 18 الف ساعه
تطوعيه تم عمل وتم العمل عليها هنا داخل
من قبل الفرقه التطوعيه والجمعيات الخيريه
وكذلك متطوعي الى الاحمر السعودي وايضا
متطوع وزاره التعليم ايضا التحدث على انه
تم فتح كافه الابواب وكافه المصليات وكذلك
هذا العام تم فتح السطح لاول مره يتم فتح
الاسطح في المسجد النبوي لاداء الصلوات في
هذا الشهر نظرا للاعداد الكبيره التي تزور
الحرم او تزور المسجد النبوي بشكل ملفت
وخصوصا في العشره الايام الاولى من
المتوقع ان تتزايد هذه الاعداد في العشر
القادمه وكان قد اعلنت رئاسه شؤون المسجد
النبوي عن نجاح الخطه التشغيليه للعشره
الاولى ويتم او جاري العمل حاليا على
تنفيذ خطه العشر الثانيه وهناك خطه مختلفه
كبيره جدا سوف يتم التعامل او العمل بها
خلال العشر الاواخر نظرا للمتوقع ان
يتوافد اعداد كبرى نظرا او نعلم انه كثير
من المعتمرين بعد انتهاء مناسك العمره
يحرسون من القدوم من مكه الى المدينه
المنوره لزياره المسجد النبوي وبعض
المعالم التاريخيه والثقافيه هنا في
المدينه ونحن كنا حريصين الاستماع اليك في
كل لحظه وانت تنقل لنا هذه المشاهد من
المدينه المنوره والمسجد النبوي وطبعا كنا
في مسائل عربيه من مكه في الحرم المكي
والان في المدينه المنوره شكرا لك سلطان
السلمي
[موسيقى]